servus skills und herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen videospiel heute jump league
es wurde bestimmt dass er damit auch
okay dass man euch nicht aber es
wirklich wundern wenn er neben mir sitzt
das ist andré eingeht kollege von mir
aus dem studium und wir werden heute mit
andré eine runde xy sagt ak heute andere
gesagt spielen das heißt andreas fier
wünsche für befehle für mich offen in
der olympic hier hat sich ein bisschen
mit dem modul auseinandergesetzt
oder auch nicht du weißt ungefähr was
passiert oder ich weiß ungefähr was
passiert ich hab mich ein bisschen an
auseinandergesetzt als jahren als
allererstes denn dein erster schritt als
micro es dass du drei bis vier zählen
wir geben dazu dieser runde und dein
ziel dann muss ich muss ich auch genannt
ein ziel ist dass ich die runde verkackt
aber es gibt auch regeln es gibt regeln
was schon mal die luca biete sagt videos
gesehen genau nämlich die regel dass du
nicht sagen darfst okay ich bring dich
um wenn das bedeutet dass ich mich
endgültig umbringen also du kannst sagen
so ok habe ich spring herunter oder im
deathmatch theoretisch auch einmal sagen
bring dich um weil wenn ich da nicht
endlich raus geht der 43 leben aber das
nicht endgültig sagen so verlasst ihr
unter das ist wobei ganz ehrlich leute
irgendwann wenn wir auch die regel
aufheben und entwürdigt auf leyen weist
dann kommt nur noch das so herzlich
willkommen zu einer neuen folge luca
sagt lukas verlass die runde
die schon zehn gold- und spricht von
gold apotheker ist das war's das ist was
ja und so weit noch alles ganz gut was
ist deine taktiken was willst du das
jetzt alles was du gerade heißt außer
wenn die tasche aus alles hier unten
alles was er außerhalb bei unten
ok alles okay
hast die wahl aber robert hat das und
das auch ja aber dass damit der zweite
satz war und ich darf auch was hier drin
war da wieder drauf mit rausnehmen
vorleute alter ist was wir entscheiden
uns hier ganz kurz wach ist schaut mal
kurz weg wird wieder sexy utah quartal
an
dabei habe ich es mal länger zweck
geworfen
nokia ist schnell weiter dass baumwolle
hat die s 1 das war der erste von vier
für dich richtig da habe ich noch
trainer ist danach so und leute euch ist
es vielleicht aufgefallen wenn er unten
auf den qualitäts button klickt wir
nehmen uns zum ersten mal 1080p auf
innovationen mehr der ohne witz andrea
das gesagte schüler fürs büro kister
mache immer aus um meine rechner kriegs
überraschenderweise sogar hin
ich bin fasziniert ich habe eigentlich
für den krassesten rechner mit einer gtx
67 blabla 7 prozessor fragte er schon
gerne mal ab ohne witz das geht so weit
bei 720p aufnahmen hat er abgehakt und
geleckt und jetzt wenn ich fullscreen
aufnehmen 1080p auf gut macht es sinn
macht es sinn
ich musste wissen nachdenke habe in
seinem kopf
ich hab ihn keine affen drin egal dafür
habe ich auch eine animation die kann
jetzt auch gerade schnell rein
die kamen jetzt endlich auch gerade
partie kleist und wir sind schon bei den
haag modulen jetzt kommt alter als ob
das baumwolle schon brecht finished wird
das bei 90 prozent der dreck sagt es
gibt zu nicht
what the [ __ ] baumwolle komme auf dein
leben klar dass das springen drauf ich
bin gab
88 ich muss oben drauf deswegen als das
jump the spring nach sich erklärte jetzt
noch komplett minecraft ich dachte es
wäre vorliegt und das ist get down
wechselst du immer ach so als hättest
dollar reicher wir kommen noch an die
küste heran 6 sekunden
die kommentare sind auch machen als
dankeschön können wir bitte eine
schweigeminute für unser equipment haben
jetzt einfach so freudig und der erste
und mit
das darfst du nicht aufmacher hast du
tatsächlich schon zwei von vier wünschen
aufgebracht haben ein bisschen wie ich
einfach in minecraft sieht auch oder
music box mache das einfach anders 22
wünsche hast du mal vorbei ganz wichtig
sollte ich auch nicht dran erinnern die
sängerin selbst haben ja ja was machen
sagt danach für jockeys erst müssen sie
auch die verhältnisse bisschen sortieren
ja ich bin ich bin erzählt christoph ott
praktisch dropbox baumwolle
ach du scheiße ok mit der single und
habe auf jeden fall keine chance gegen
den 32
das komitee doch der hat burkhard bock
es wichtig auch auch bitte nicht so
genannte praxis gegenseitig oder das
ganze thema wenn leute mit können so
eklig und halten und latinos unser
letzter komplett gegangene just müssen
theoretisch immer leute kennt man auch
in die hand bekommen aber das sieht gut
aus jawoll damit ein bisschen weg
geklatscht hier jetzt regenerieren wir
da unten auch ohne food wir sind immer
noch bei dreileben wir haben keinen
druck mehr
okay die hat hat mich als ich aus
plastik sehen dass trotzdem die gleiche
kerbe die manchmal ist auch wieder raus
und geklatscht junge einer das so
gemeint was wir für gut aber doch wieder
wichtiger daten keine diamanten folgen
hätte diamanten und eine eigentlich hat
man ja in fms kaufen können ich hätte
eine chance gegen baumwolle gehabt und
jetzt verpacke ich einfach danke schön
nein danke danke dass ich gebe danke
dass du dabei bis heute ja danke dass
ich vergessen eine ehre verlieren zu
lassen
jetzt.de kuba combo spitzenelf alles da
und da ist aber noch ein diamant oder
nice nice nice will ich nicht werden wie
dies nicht werden das nicht angreifen
das neue werk springt da die
verteidigung habe ich zurückschlagen
das leben ich habe also seid also jetzt
so locker so ich bin so pvp gott oh mein
gott das ist immer noch zwei leben rehe
1er bessere ausrüstung die amateure ich
habe auch noch verkraften
die zeit ausreicht ich sag ja er wollte
er der alte und 1945 49 pfeile und hat
ein leben meine wünsche aufgebraucht
bloß keine wünsche mir jetzt bin ist es
nur noch das musste ich das heißt die
frage ob das passt
jetzt als es enthält
jetzt soll der drei fälle gefassten
bitte genau mein alter war ja soll wie
viele einschläge kommen ständig zu
retten wie viel da ich bin drei pfeile
gegeben oder ist wieder halt auch so
schlecht ist wird man das unfassbar wie
viel hast du noch bitte noch 54 habe ich
schon verbraucht und jetzt kriegt er den
ersten daneben
jetzt habe ich den drei fälle gegeben
das muss weiter eine combo ja ja wohl
egal wo leiter der hast es nicht
geschafft ob acer jetzt hätte ich gerne
aber das könnte ich aber denken leute ja
leute andres anderes kanal mcp vp pro
3001 player hd sgg pvp sind sie unter
einer beschreibung ist unser besteuerung
ist verlinkt bisschen langer links des
weges verlinkt und ja das war es von
heute mit sagen wir sind es morgen
wieder mit dem neuen video bis dahin
haut rein macht's gut und